[موسيقى]
في ناس بيقولوا لا هذه هيك الشغلات خرافيه
او روحانيه لا لانه لو هذي الشغله صح زي
ما ببعض بفكر ما بتلاقي شجار للطفل مش انا
شرحك شرحك كبده في ناس انا بعرف ناس قطوف
عنب هيك على وجهكم عنب اسمر هذه وحمه كله
سبحانه من خلق سبحان من لون
[موسيقى]
من سنه 1955
واخذت هاي المهنه متوارثه عن طريق والدي
الله يرحمه
سوق الوهميه بوفر
الفواكه اللي مش موجوده غير موسمها
بنامنها احنا من فلسطين من الشام من لبنان
ومن خزن بضاعه الشتاء للصيف بضاعه الصيف
للشتاء
[موسيقى]
لهون وبساله شو الوحمه وين احنا كجيران
يعني بالخمسينات على زمان
المرحوم ابوه ابوه كان يجاوب هيك شغله بس
كيف شغلاتهم كمان ما كانتش شغلات تفريز ما
تفريز
يجيب البضاعه من سوريا من لبنان
كله الا عنده
الفستق الحلبي الاخضر ما بتلاقيش بعمان
كله كان الا عنده
العنب الزين هذا الحبه الكبيره الامريكي
[موسيقى]
يعني كل الشغلات اللي بيجي وحمه تلاقيها
طريقه حفظ الفواكه عن طريق التنشير
وعن طريق التفريز في اصناف
بتتفرز وفي اصناف
تتنشف مثل الرمان من نشفه عن طريق
الهواء بقعد سنه سنتين ثلاثه زي ما هو بس
عباره عن القشر بتنشف ولكن من الداخل زي
ما هو يعني في فواكه ما بتتنشف بتتفرج مثل
اللوز الكرز المشمش والتوت يعني الفواكه
العاديه
البطيخ برضه
ما بتخزن بالتفريز بتخزن عن طريق
يعني
هواء يعني يكون مهوم معلق بالتهويه مناسبه
بعيد عن الشمس تطلبوا شغلات غريبه عجيبه
يعني فاكهه التنين اسمها
وبيطلبوا لي ستار فروت الساعه ثلاثه ونص
اربعه الفجر
ومضطر انا يعني
البي لهم طلبهم بس بتيجي طلباتهم يعني
بوقت يعني بكون احنا في سابع نومه
في ناس بيطلعوا يعني بشوف اللي بطلع على
وجهه خاصه البنات بيطلع على وجههم حبه كرز
عنب ورق دوالي بطلع لوز يعني يعني زي
شبيهه قطعه البطيخ كان موسم البطيخ مقطوع
بشهر واحد وما كان عندي فبعد ست شهور
بعد سته شهور المراه الحامل
يعني جابت بنت
وفرجتني اياها انه هالكيكه توحمت على بطيخ
وما لقت فطلع فرجتني وجه الطفله يعني
مرسومه عليها قطعه بطيخ
[موسيقى]